what's the verdict everything looks
great so far I think you know we've got
a lot of people going to Apple music
we've got a lot of people trying a lot
of new music and with the numbers that
we released tomorrow on downloads we
don't see any negative impact on
downloads at this point Steven your
review is a bit more mixed than that not
everything looks so great according to
you sure I mean I think Apple nailed the
song selection they have at least as
much as everybody else if not a little
bit more but I'm not sold yet on the
interface I mean Spotify and Google Play
and title all have their foibles and
their problems but I think apple's
system is a little harder to navigate
and harder to use just on a daily basis
than the competitors interesting David
you know you've covered the music
industry for 20 years you worked at
Universal Music Group how worried should
Spotify Pandora be you know on the other
hand we're seeing that Spotify had its
best week in the apple app store for
like a year and a half yeah yeah and I
think that's the the good news here is
that this is bringing streaming to more
people it's bringing more people into
the ecosystem streaming and and they can
learn how to discover and how to play
more music more easily more often and
that's what we're seeing is that people
are spending more time listening to
music and services like this really just
increase the profile of streaming music
so Steven some some quotes from your
review it's like a 40 year old wearing
abercrombie and fitch explain sure so I
think they built Apple music on top of
itunes to to a large degree and so on
your computer you're still using itunes
on your phone you're using Apple music
and there's all of these shiny new
interfaces and colorful screens but at
the bottom of it it doesn't service
usability it makes things look nice or
in some cases not so nice but i think
it's it's less about utility and more
about kind of whiz-bang appearances so
I've been popping out two beats one all
day their global radio service it's a
little much for me it was a little much
in the middle of a workday maybe for
when I go clubbing once a year if I make
it out once a year but what do you guys
think of beats wine I mean this has been
the most hype
part of the service david is it is it
all it's cracked up to be well I think
one of the best things that it does is
it brings personality to music and it
brings personality to a service that you
know there's a lot of streaming services
out there that have playlists there's a
lot of streaming services out there that
are simulcasts or built upon things that
people like to listen to but this is
bringing something that is one we're
going to try some new things here we're
going to expose music fans to some new
things but we're also going to give it a
lot of personality and you can see that
the people on the air there certainly do
have plenty of personality Stephen on
the other hand you say it feels like
your parents pretending to be cool until
you come home past curfew time I mean I
think playing censored songs hurts them
a little bit with the attempt to seem
cool and in touch it's just sort of
jarring and if you listen to a lot of
radio you're used to that I think a lot
of the people listening to beats one
probably aren't used to that but I do
agree that the personalities are great
and I think that the people coming
through in the curated playlists are
also a huge strength I've really never
seen curated playlists that are this
good let's talk about that for a moment
that you and I were both at WWDC we
thought we heard Apple touting the
importance of human curation but is this
really better than my pandora playlist
um in my experience it has been and I
say in the review that machines don't
necessarily make better playlists than
human beings or human beings make better
playlists than the machines but I think
in this case apple hired the right
people they pulled editors from places
like pitchfork and rolling stone and in
some cases collaborated with both of
those publications so you have people
who really know music and who know what
people are listening to and what people
want making playlists so it's a case of
the right people or the right algorithm
when you need it